[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
pat connaughton the
star of the milwaukee bucks former notre
dame fighting irishman joining us on the
program pat
could you have played a basketball game
last night
uh honestly with all the adrenaline i
had probably uh the excitement coming
off
it it was uh it was something special it
was great to be out there and
obviously have my teammates around and
celebrate with them last night but
uh you know we probably could have
pulled it off if needed be
uh who was the mvp of the celebration
uh who pj tucker and bobby portis
i give a co-mbp awards uh you know
they were uh they were phenomenal they
enjoyed it i was super happy for pj
i mean pj's had an incredible career and
obviously this was uh something that
uh he was looking for and he did a lot
of things to
help us get it so uh he deserved to be
the mvp of the celebration
do you just wear your uniform out of the
arena
ah so funny story i didn't i showered
eventually and then
obviously went to the after party and
after dinner and stuff like that but
i do recall one of my teammates did show
up to the after party still wearing the
entire uniform
shoes tied shooting sleeve on well
i saw giannis checking into a hotel at
four in the morning i got a picture from
a buddy
and he's got the trophies and he's in
full uniform he's g
he's at the front desk checking into a
hotel
at it was like he was checking into the
game at four in the morning
i mean you saw his uh chick-fil-a order
the next morning when he said he didn't
sleep so
uh giannis is i think the one of the
coolest part
was about this whole thing is the world
got to see a little bit of janice's
personality
i mean he's uh quiet sometimes the media
and obviously he's very focused on
accomplishing our goals but when you get
him and he's outside and he's in the
locker room outside of uh
you know a media and business setting
the kid's funny and
i was happy that the world got to see
that yeah he came off as
a great a great kid i mean i shouldn't
say kid
i mean he's just he he had humility
yeah sense of humor uh timing uh
there was a lot and and i was glad that
he was able to showcase that because
i think we're always going to be looking
at him going hey you can win all those
mvps
you got to win championships well now he
got a hall pass he's on scholarship for
a little while that people aren't going
to go hey when are you going to win a
championship
when did you realize though what he was
capable of doing
uh you know the the first day i got here
three years ago
and i signed with the bucks i was uh
we were having you know some open gym
type stuff and we were all working out
in the morning and
you know i'm a second round guy a guy
that was trying to make sure that i had
a role on this team so
at night you know i'd come back and i'd
work out and i think
um you know i did it in portland there's
something that i have to do it's
something that you know i enjoyed doing
but
you got to put time into your craft and
uh the
coolest part that i think people don't
know is when i came back
and continued to come back giannis was
there uh and giannis looked at me like
what are you doing here i looked at him
like
what are you doing here i'm the guy that
has to be here why are you here and so
uh just the things that he does behind
the scenes and the time and
uh effort that he puts in that people
don't see i think
made me realize that that he is a
championship type guy
and then it was just watching his growth
as a leader uh you know he had obviously
the
physical work ethic that you would i
would see on a you know daily basis but
the vocal leadership that he's grown
into that type of role he's grown into
to where
when he got hurt and he was out for
those last two games in atlanta he was
still
present on the bench he was still being
vocal both individually and collectively
to the team to teammates and
uh and pulling them aside to give them
the confidence to understand that
uh you know he was here he had our backs
even though he wasn't out there and it
was on us to make sure we had his
i have a scary injury though pat because
you had guys former players who came on
this show and said
they didn't know if he'd even play again
in the rest of the postseason that's why
i think we're
underselling what he accomplished in the
finals based off of
the hyper-extended knee i mean
remarkable
yeah i mean look he's he's a freak he's
got that nickname for a reason but
uh i think the funny part is exactly
what you said you know he
it was questionable if he was going to
play against the postseason he was able
to make it back for game one of the
finals
and because of the type of
uh obviously uh series he had i think
people kind of forget
hey it was a question if he was going to
play again but because of the
performances he had
people kind of took it for granted and
you know he just wanted to win
and that was the coolest part about
being alongside a superstar all he cared
about was
winning pat connaughton the milwaukee
bucks guard joining us on the program
when did you kind of find
your role your your place in this lineup
uh you know i think over the course of
the last few years i've i've found it in
spurts
and i've been i've had impacts in spurts
and uh you know i've enjoyed playing
alongside
uh you know my teammates i've been here
for three years the new ones that i've
just got here this year
the coaching staff that's been here for
three years and the organization in
general
all the way from ownership down to
management etc uh but
i think it was just a confidence that
was continued to be instilled to me and
you know when dante went down who's you
know a tremendous player
it wasn't about trying to do more it was
just about trying to continue to do what
i do
be my own guy and make sure that it was
just done on a longer period of time
what did you keep from the final game
uh i kept my uniform i kept my shoes i
kept hats shirts
um but i think the coolest part was the
moments the
the pictures the things that uh were
just pure celebration joy
i mean the little uh segment that's been
going around with me and bobby porters
in the interview after the games like
uh all those little moments that were
you drunk there
pat i personally know i was not but
it was uh it was just a it was a genuine
moment it was something that you know me
and bobby looked at each other and we've
obviously uh you know been part of the
quote-unquote benchmark throughout this
entire season we've had each other's
back we've played together and
uh we've prided ourselves on making sure
we made the winning plays and
uh that was a winning interview when you
left the building how many people were
still outside oh a lot
i mean i think that was something that
was the most unique about
this team and this city and uh you know
the support that we've gotten i mean
chris middleton said it best in the
locker room after the game you know he
was a part of a
15 win team not too long ago here and so
uh to see that come full circle and to
see the fans uh
continue to support them through thick
and thin they continue to support us
through thick and thin
there had to have still been tens of
thousands of people out there there were
65
70 000 people out there during the game
not including the ones that were inside
and
uh you know it'll be pretty cool to be
able to go through the streets of
milwaukee on a
uh bus boat wherever the heck we're
doing it on and
show support with them aren't you glad
you passed up on that baseball career
now
i am uh you know i think the coolest
part about that is seeing it come full
circle there are so many people that
um you know told me baseball was the
path that i should take but
to be able to show the next generation
of kids you know you can be a
multi-sport athlete
you don't have to specialize at a young
age it can help you become more athletic
it can help you become more mentally
tough
and you can still accomplish things you
want to accomplish uh and
you know i told christian yelich at the
game maybe in you know
eight nine ten years i'll be uh pitching
with him on the
on the brewers and trying to win a world
series here oh so you haven't given up
on that dream
uh no not yet uh you know i'm focused on
the current dream that i'm doing but
uh i take time in the off season still
throw a little bit it's kind of a mental
release for me
it i've always loved being out there and
uh it's a different type of
feel when you're on the mound and uh
when you're out in a baseball park
throwing it around
under the lights so uh it's not
something that i've
fully given up on but i'm enjoying this
ride i'm enjoying this journey and i
enjoy
you know being able to have some of the
successes that not many people thought i
would have at this level
well congrats it was a wonderful season
and uh
certainly being part of something
special you know how milwaukee's held on
to that team that won it back in 1971
so you got 50 years at least
if you don't win another championship
they're gonna you're you're still gonna
be held in high regard there so pat
congratulations appreciate it dp thank
you for having me on show i'm a huge fan
that's pat connaughton the uh guard for
uh the world champion
milwaukee bucks